hey youtubers is Charlie and if you saw
my PaleyFest video for air on the flash
yesterday you know greg berlanti teased
that they might be doing wally west in
season two so I wanted to do an
explainer video for his comic book
history and you know some changes that
the show might make to him based on
what's going on in the new 52 and some
of the things they've already done with
the characters they just they've already
made some changes to the West family so
they can't do a straight-up adaptation
of the pre new 52 wally west and for
those that are asking about the clips
that they posted they posted new footage
from the rest of the season from the
flash and arrow because they haven't
posted high quality versions of those
trailers yet I'm just gonna wait to do a
breakdown but just quick synopsis Eddie
Thawne there's some very villainous
looking stuff it looked like he shot a
couple cops so it looks like he goes off
the rails completely that might start
the sequence of events that leads to one
of his descendants becoming the
reverse-flash just speculation but on
arrow
Quentin is seen inside the arrow cave
saying I got you now son of a so
it seems like he's gonna go after team
arrow don't worry they'll post
high-quality versions of those soon so
I'll do breakdowns whenever they do that
moving into Wally West's territory so he
was the modern age Flash DC brought in
after Barry Allen died during Infinite
Crisis in the 80s thankfully the TV
shows is opting for sanity and making it
a much linear story so is it's much
easier to follow if you don't read
comics so don't worry about that some of
you may have heard me talk about it in
previous videos but what they're doing
on the TV shows taking the Barry Allen
character and blending it with the Wally
West run pre new 52 so you get a lot of
like the classic characters from the
Barry Allen Silver Age comics with a lot
of the tone and the humor from the Wally
West run there's a lot of mixing and
matching characters from both runs -
that's why whenever they introduce new
characters I always try and say which
issue that they started out in Wally
West debuted in the comics in volume 2
that Silver Age the Barry Allen era
issue 110 he was created by carmine
infantino and John Broome the same guys
that created most of the Rogues a lot of
that like the Barry Allen Silver Age
characters he started out as Kid Flash
whenever he first got powers he hit he
had the red costume just made to look a
lot like Barry's costume but then they
gave him the yellow Kid Flash costume
subsequent versions of Kid Flash like
Bart Allen for instance have honored
that like they've worn the yellow very
originally wally west had this really
strained relationship with his parents
so he looks to his uncle Barry and iris
as role models one day while he was
visiting the Central City crime lab
where Barry worked he was caught in an
accident just like Barry's accident that
gave him flash power so Wally West got
flash powers in the exact same way I
know they play with it like the TV show
is doing a more modern take on the
origin story whenever Wally West was
created in the comics they hadn't
thought of the Speed Force yet that was
until mark Wade's run way way later
so Barry Allen originally got his powers
with a normal lightning bolt and a
combination of a bunch of different
chemicals and that's what happened to
Wally West on the TV show like they had
an Easter Egg for that like there's a
bunch of chemicals that spill whenever
Barry gets his powers but the lightning
bolt that hits him isn't a normal
lightning bolt it's the Speed Force
itself hitting him and infusing his body
if you saw the Justice League flashpoint
movie they honored the original origin
story where it's a combination of
chemicals in a regular lightning bolt if
you don't read the comics don't worry if
they bring Wally West on this show he'll
probably just be infused with the dark
matter just like Barry Allen was and
that'll be like the Speed Force it's
them
tapping into the dark matter that's what
they're calling the Speed Force so after
we first debuted in the flash comics
Wally West went on to join Teen Titans
as Kid Flash the writers got tired of
telling stories with like a really young
version of him so they gave him this
weird disease where by he would start
aging faster and faster the more he used
his speed force powers it's a funny
comic book way to explain why they want
a character to go from being a kid to
being an adult really fast they just I
guess they felt like the adult version
of Wally West to be more interesting so
cut to Infinite Crisis in the mid 80s
Barry Allen sacrifices himself to save
the earth in the final battle with the
anti monitors forces Wally West is
struck by an antimatter blast that cures
his disease so he's frozen in his adult
state and Jay Garrick eventually
encourages him to take the mantle oh the
flash so so he puts down the title of
Kid Flash and just becomes the flash
proper that lasted all the way up to
flashpoint I mean they did bring barry
allen back during flash rebirth during
final crisis but Wally West was still
technically the main flash of the main
universe post-crisis after he took the
mantle of the flash they also made a
whole bunch of changes of the characters
they used Infinite Crisis
is on Infinite Earths 2d power like all
their characters so Superman got less
powerful and wally west instead of being
able to run faster than the speed of
light like Barry Allen he could only run
a little bit faster than the speed of
sound but they changed that to overtime
he slowly got more powerful more and
more powerful eventually there was this
story called the once and future flash
Barry Allen returned from the dead but
it turned out to be a Oh Bart Thawne
masquerading as Barry in order to defeat
him Wally West has to overcome this
mental block that's preventing him from
accessing the full extent of his powers
so after he defeats the reverse-flash
the a Oh Bart Thawne reverse-flash he's
back up to Barry Allen levels of power
they did change his powers a little bit
like he can't do exactly the same things
that Barry does but they gave him extra
powers in addition to that so Markway
this is like Mark Waid run he introduced
the idea of the Speed Force and they
used that as like the scientific
explainer for how there could be other
speedsters where their powers came from
they also introduced the idea of giving
and stealing speed for power so like
wally west can steal speed from the
rivers flash in the reverse flash can
steal speed from Wally West they tease
this a little bit on the show where
Harrison wells is like slowly absorbing
Speed Force energy teasing the idea that
you know he's trying to get Barry Allen
to be faster and faster so that he can
siphon more Speed Force power during the
90s they they try to take a more
realistic approach to the character that
that's when he started having to eat
tons and tons of food on the current TV
show right now Cisco just created super
energy bars for Barry to eat I mean if
you ever watched the original flash show
with John Wesley Shipp there's a scene
where he had to eat like 20 pizzas
whenever geoff johns took over the comic
book that's when wally west got married
to Linda Park they had let a lot of
their own adventures to where like Linda
Park and their children got Speed Force
powers don't know if the show's gonna
get into that territory because we do
have Linda Park but they chant you know
they've combined Linda Park with the
Barry Allen Run where she's dating Barry
there was even this dark flash storyline
where an alternate timeline Wally West
tried to take over the real Wally West's
life he was like this older scarred
version of Wally from a timeline where
Linda Park had been murdered things had
gone to so he usually traveled to
the main timeline and tried to pass
himself off as Wally eventually he did
leave and tried to find his own timeline
but it's a slightly different take on
the DC universe
and it kind of contradicts multiverse
theory so I don't think the TV show is
gonna try and do any dark flash stuff
and just to be clear the dark flash is a
completely different character than any
of the reverse flashes although right
now in the new 52 comics Barry Allen is
fighting a future version of himself I
think that's why a lot of people think
that Harrison wells might be a future
version of Barry just because like right
now in the comics Barry's fighting a
version of himself from 20 years in the
future that's gone super dark I don't
think that's what the show is doing
because mostly the show draws from
classic Silver Age Barry Allen and
modern age Wally West's not like new 52
stuff but we'll find out like they'll
completely explain everything by the end
of this season so fast forward to
yesterday they kind of confirmed Wally
West kind of mean it's not a
confirmation they just said if we're
gonna do it we would do it in season two
right now in the new 52 universe there's
a Daniel West that's the brother of iris
West and there's a Wally West two
completely different characters Daniel
West was introduced as the new 52
version of the reverse-flash he's the
brother of iris West
so clearly the show is not doing Daniel
West Wally West was just reintroduced as
part of this like Barry versus future
Barry's storyline it gets really
complicated but basically he has a
completely new backstory he's not
Barry's nephew anymore it's a more
Street version of the character and then
they're just now starting to develop him
so we'll see which direction they take
the character but if the TV show does
Wally West what they'll probably do is
either they'll do like a new 52 version
whereby Barry Allen and the
reverse-flash mess with the timeline so
much that it creates ripples and a Wally
West character gets Speed Force powers
as a result or iris will have like a
cousin that will come visit the town and
he'll get caught in a particle
accelerator accident and get Speed Force
powers some of what the producers said
at PaleyFest
implies that they might be trying for a
flashpoint type storyline whereby you
know the reverse flash or Barry Allen
changes something in the past and it
creates a lot of butterfly effects
changing the characters for season two
it'd be like a backdoor to Caitlin snow
turning evil becoming killer frost
getting powers I don't know that they're
necessarily gonna do that it's just one
possibility for a way they could
introduce a new Wally West character and
give him Speed Force powers if he
doesn't already have them that's
actually really good jumping-off point
so here's
big question for you guys if they bring
Wally West on the show and give him
speed force powers how do you want him
to get those Speed Force powers do you
want it to be some sort of like messing
with a time line situation where an
alternate reality is created a la
flashpoint or do you want to see like
the in the main time line Barry Allen do
something with this before some you know
weird power situation where he grants
power to a new character if the show has
told us anything it's that there is no
limit to the amount of accidents that
can be caused by messing around at STAR
Labs so I think if Wally West does get
powers it'll definitely be involved with
shenanigans going down at STAR Labs so
don't forget new episode of the flash
next week it's episode 15 they're
introducing time travel and the new
weather wizard be sure to subscribe to
get my video I'll post it right into the
episode airs and new episode of arrow
that's gonna be episode 16 they're out
of sync it's gonna be a little bit weird
but it's fine arrows gonna take a much
deeper dive into League of Assassins
racial ghouls gonna explain his offer so
while you guys wait for those episodes
to drop you can click here for my
PaleyFest breakdown words I explained
some of the stuff that they talked about
and the stuff they tease and you can
click here to get ready for a Walking
Dead tonight thanks so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight now let's all
do the thing